there are people that exercise
seven days a week work out two hours a
day and still
cannot lose even an ounce so the
question is why what makes someone
be able to lose weight and other people
cannot today we're going to talk about
that
if you look around you're going to
notice that most people fall into one of
four
body shapes some people hold a weight in
the stomach
as a sagging belly some people as a
protruded
some people hold their weight in the
saddlebag hip area and the arms
yet other people will be big everywhere
so i developed the body type
system of weight loss and today we're
going to talk about what's behind that
because
if there's something going on inside
your body that's off or out of balance
the outside is going to be shaped
differently
and there's nothing worse than doing all
this work and not getting results
i mean there are people that they just
keep failing and failing and failing
it's not that they're crazy or lazy or
have low willpower
it's they're not getting results so
today's about getting to the root
and what's very interesting is you don't
really have a weight problem
i know it sounds weird some of you are
like have you seen me in the mirror
you have a weight symptom it's really a
hormone
problem or a slow metabolism
but let's talk about hormones because
there's a lot of confusion i had a lady
who said i don't need to come to your
seminar dr bird because i had all my
hormones removed
you you have 600 hormones in your body
we're going to cover each one of them
today i hope you have a notebook now
we're not going to cover all this
but the ones we're going to talk about
are the fat burning hormones but let's
just define what a hormone is i need a
volunteer
how about you great once you stand right
here
she's like do i have to just go in this
front row
and i need another volunteer yeah how
about you
so you can just stand right here okay so
you're gonna be the fat cell
okay you're gonna be the thyroid gland
okay okay so now thyroid um
and you're gonna communicate i'm gonna
just put your fingers in your ear just
pretend like you can't hear me okay
okay good so now thyroid say hello to
the fat cell
hello okay say burn fat
burn fat
okay now do you have any kids three have
you ever
talked to a child he ignored you the
first time what do you do
say it again okay good
burn fat do you actually increase the
volume too yeah yeah
burn fat okay after a while her face is
going to get red
so hormones are the communication sent
across the distance over here and it's
supposed to connect
into two little holes they're called
receptors hormones are communications
they have millions of functions but the
one we're talking about is the fat
burning hormone so we have the gland
that makes the hormone
it gets sent to the bloodstream it gets
received and it's supposed to burn fat
most people this is what's going on the
communication is being sent but it's not
being listened to
so that's why they keep gaining weight
so
thank you very much and thank you very
much see
now that you understand hormones let's
go into the first body type
which which is the thyroid gland
now the thyroid is this body type right
here where you gain weight
all over equally not in any one location
now your thyroid is located right in the
base of your neck right here just put
your fingers on your thyroid
lower yeah right there it's about two
and a half inches wide
it comes from the latin word which means
shield
thyroid because it looks like a little
shield looks like
this okay now
if the thyroid is not working you're
going to start developing
too much what is called potential
energy what's another name for a
potential
energy fat very good
how many feel like you have too much
potential energy it sounds better
doesn't it
there's a better ring to it we're going
to get a t-shirt i'm not fat at
potential energy
so that's what it is so fat
how many of you be honest don't like
your fat
yeah now why does your body make it
if it just makes you miserable does it
have a purpose
like maybe people think it's a cushion
or an insulator to sit down
no it's a survival mechanism
in other words it is developed
on the evolutionary chain of survival so
it helps you against it protects against
starvation
famine and stress so your body
has stored fat to help you
so now you have a different viewpoint
that's trying to help you right but the
question is how do we get rid of it
right
if we have too much well what do most
people do
they go on a diet what do what do they
do
what's a diet it's a starvation
hello so what's going to happen the more
they diet the more they starve
themselves the more they cut calories
the more they count calories portion
control everything in moderation
you end up creating more potential
energy the exact thing you're trying to
get rid of
so the things that people do to lose
weight are the things that are ruining
the metabolism
so with a thyroid you'll have problems
with excess weight because the thyroid
goes into every single cell in the body
you're going to every weight your cell
is going to expand and get bigger that's
why you're big equally everywhere
now the first symptom of a thyroid would
be
cravings to carbohydrates
okay starches
breads pasta cereal crackers biscuits
waffles pancakes muffins sodas
juice alcohol mad dog 20 20.
all of those things are carbohydrates
now how many of you ever ate something
that you know you shouldn't have eaten
at least once before
got one two three four five six
how do people justify it when they eat
something bad
everything in moderation i deserve it
that's a good one
people are starving in russia you've got
to eat everything on your plate
just a little bit i'll drink more water
to flush it out
you can't be perfect all the time so
when you do something like that
what happens is you end up you have to
make it okay so you
invent a reason for eating that thing
and so it stacks up
um i went to i was at uh the health food
store
and i was shopping and i saw one of my
clients um and she was um i was just
watching i was by the salad bar looking
through the glass and i saw her over
there by the
red section and she kept going close to
this little um
brownie tray i was just watching
to see if she was going to get in and
she would go closer and then she would
back up and
she'd look back and come back here and
then eventually she
before she grabbed it she looked looked
left and right and she ate it
and then she looked right up and we
connected eyes
her face turned white as a ghost and she
just went with a shop card this way
so i ran after her and i'm saying i'm
like listen
it's okay just relax because if i didn't
if i didn't talk to her make it okay she
would just i would never see her again
so people tend to hide those little
secrets with cheating and stuff
it's okay to cheat as long as you tell
me
don't keep a secret just get it out
because all we have to do is we have to
find out why you're craving but if you
have a thyroid problem you're going to
crave the
the pleasure foods breads potato
starch rice okay uh sourdough bread out
of the oven
with butter okay they like that for some
reason
so um they crave carbohydrates
they have problems with their hair the
hair starts getting thinner
brittle they they lose their hair and
they comb it
because those are proteins they have
problems with their nails they get
vertically ridged nails those are up and
down ridges on the nails
okay let's see what we got here oh you
got yours polished there
oh okay so can you call 9-1-1 please
so the ridges the nails could mean
thyroid the problem with the thyroid
you'll have loose um skin right here
right here how many of you know anyone
like that maybe like a co-worker or a
relative a neighbor
yeah someone else so we have a thin skin
dry hair you lose your eyebrows on the
outer part right here first
that would be thyroid
thyroid cases have cold feet they throw
socks to bed
someone told me doesn't everyone i go no
that's not normal so they have a
temperature problem
so they have problems they're they're
tired they
they could sleep for many many hours but
there's they don't feel refreshed
when they get up okay so that would be
thyroid any question about the thyroid
thyroid cases do not absorb vitamins too
well
okay so vitamins
because the metabolism is so low they
don't break those things down
there's over a hundred intracellular
enzymes those are those little chemicals
in the body that break stuff down
that are get shut down with the thyroid
so it's very expensive urine to be
taking all these vitamins because it's
going to go right
through you so
let's just talk as a side note not only
is it a problem with absorption of
vitamins that but most vitamins are made
synthetically
now let's just show you something in
nature vitamins
always come in complexes
ascorbic acid is one part of the vitamin
c
complex okay it's just the antioxidant
its purpose is to protect the real good
stuff which is vitamin j
p k and copper these are
this is a natural vitamin c complex that
comes in nature
this is synthetic right here which is
ascorbic acid
what's very interesting about that is
that
this comes from corn starch and sulfuric
acid that's how they make ascorbic acid
there's no vitamin c in corn yet they're
making
vitamin c when it's artificial though
when you
take ascorbic acid in large quantities
which
mainly you'll see in synthetic over 500
milligrams in these pills
which if it was natural be the size of a
golf ball and as a pill
when you take too much of this it will
create deficiencies of these other parts
it will literally create a vitamin c
deficiency i had a guy he went to mexico
and he was going to cancer therapy and
he took all this
100 000 milligrams of injected vitamin c
but it was really ascorbic acid
he ended up with bleeding gums that's a
sign of vitamin c deficiency
varicose veins spider veins hemorrhoids
and extreme fatigue that's all the signs
of scurvy
so you always want to look on the back
of label
and be able to read the label to see if
it's real like comes from actual plants
you don't want to have to pronounce like
can't pronounce these chemicals okay
so most vitamins are made synthetically
99 and
even the most popular ones which i'm not
going to mention any of those vitamins
names okay
centrum silver but what happens is that
there's another one called calcium
carbonate that's a mineral
that's sold as a
calcium supplement right calcium
carbonate is limestone
it's not it's like it's like a rock
you'd be better off chewing on the
cement out there
than you would taking that vitamin so
when you take your vitamin and you feel
this heavy bottle
it's like a paper weight it's just
mainly calcium carbonate which is
limestone
it's not going to be absorbed it's just
going to it's going to cause kidney
stones
so read the labels make sure the
vitamins and minerals come from plants
that you can pronounce not synthetics
most
vitamins or minerals are made from
metals
or rocks or salts which
don't really get absorbed so there's a
big difference when people say there's
no difference there's a big difference
and then compound that the fact that you
have a thyroid case you can't absorb
anything no wonder we have
that the vitamins that you take aren't
really working
okay now the next body type we're going
to talk about
is going to be called the adrenal
now the adrenal gland sits on top of the
kidney
right here you've got two of them go
ahead and put your fingers on your
adrenals
now the adrenal gland is a stress gland
how many ever experienced stress before
got one two
three four five six give me an example
of what stresses people
out work traffic
children kids husbands
being overweight school relationships
life finances wow you guys can relate to
that
um how many have ever had a stressful
relationship before at least once
twice okay we'll stop right there
um so the adrenal reacts and adapts the
body to stress
so if you pretend like you're being
chased by a tiger for the next 10 years
and how your body would react to that
that's what happens with the adrenals
over time when it burns out
well if you're being chased by a tiger
you're not going to be able to sleep
okay
you're not going to be able to reproduce
so you're going to have problems with
hormones
reproductive hormones you're going to
problems with digestion
you're getting problems with blood
pressure and cholesterol and all these
other things with blood sugars because
you're running on sugar so i'm going to
go through all of them
but the adrenals regulate stress and
stress
does accumulate yes you're like a bucket
and you filled up in fact there is
always some stress
that has occurred right before you
started
developing a stubborn weight issue
always
if you ask a person they think it's just
calories right well
if you take it back when did you start
gaining weight what happened just before
that
you're going to find that they had a
baby c-section a surgery
a hysterectomy tubal ligation they got
married
they got a divorce on that same day now
they have just a lot of different
stresses i've had people even as kids be
be overweight and many times it comes
after an asthma attack
or an ear infection or a throat
infection so many things that can stress
the body out
but stress does accumulate and over time
you develop too many applications on
your
desktop computer which is your body
so all these things accumulate and
you're just like a bucket of stress
you're kind some people when we measure
the inside of you are so jacked up
they can't sleep they can't relax so i
would say
probably the biggest thing that stresses
people out are other
people is that true there's certain
personality types that kind of get to
you
you got the whiner right they're like um
will you please help me will you please
help me
do they ever accept your help no
you just want to help you just want to
like okay let me push you downstairs now
you want my help
so it's like you have winders you have
the antagonistic person who's rude
you have the real depressed person that
brings you down
you'll give them a solution they say no
that will never work or you have those
really happy people that are always this
happy
that doesn't stress me out but sometimes
it's like if you're depressed you don't
really like these happy people
they're just too positive all the time
but there's one personality type
that really gets on my nerves and they
call it the um
passive aggressive called underminers
now let me show you what they what they
look like so everyone look at me very
very
hostile right now
you're smiling look at me very mean
okay now smile hi
nice to meet you they're gonna backstab
you
to your face they told you they stood up
for you but they actually ruin your
reputation
they love gossip how many of you know
anyone like that
they give you a compliment but they
follow it up with a sharp critical
comment
they'll say something like hey that's a
nice jacket was it on sale
i'm like who would ever say that it's
like oh that's a nice haircut
did you get at cheap cuts my uncle
i mean um actually yes it was my uncle
um he goes uh congratulations you
graduated as
a chiropractor congratulations hey why
don't you want to become a real doctor
so you have people that are bringing you
up and people are bringing you down
right so those people they bring you
down covertly
so they're very introverting they'll
they'll do something like this
are you feeling okay you look really
tired are you sick
and you're like i was fine until you
said that
so i do have a way of getting back at
these people if you'd like
to know about that anyone want to know
the technique
okay just reverse the flow just do back
to them
have you has that been growing for a
while
you don't have anything in your face
they'll be in the bathroom for hours
looking at their face going is there
anything on here
because they're introverting you so yeah
okay so let's move on to something less
stressful
but if you're in a relationship like
that or someone's
connected and you're trying to reason
with them don't hold your breath
you can't reason with them that's what
frustrates you because you just want to
get them to see
can't you see that you're crazy no
they're not going to see that
they have to be right they'd rather be
right than successful
so you're just better off just ignoring
them okay
so adrenal when the adrenal gland gets
burnt out your tolerance or stress goes
down you don't tolerate people anymore
people get on your nerves you become
edgy
especially incompetent people
people that make mistakes you kind of
like you might react more than you
should right
you're not going crazy okay it's the
adrenals because the tolerance
of stress your ability to tolerate
stress stuff this
kind of buffers it so sometimes that
buffer goes down and you're
and you're just kind of on edge all the
time um
the way you think it's not linear it's
like popcorn thoughts just come in there
like this
your memory starts the adrenal affects
the gps in the brain
so it's kind of like you're going
downstairs you're like um
what am i looking for again i've got to
backtrack
okay um you'll be talking to someone but
you're actually
having another conversation in your head
you might be waiting for the person to
stop talking so you can talk
because you're kind of thinking too fast
it's going too fast
what you're doing you're solving
problems 24 7 you can't stop
solving problems in fact you can't stop
thinking so with adrenal
they do a lot of thinking and because
they're in a survival mode
it's called flight or fight mode that is
uh
the problem with that is it stirs up the
adrenals even more
what they should be doing is just turn
it off for at least
i don't know like a half hour a day go
for a walk
look at a tree a bird a cloud and just
get space don't get the headphones on
and
you know look at your computer all the
time how many of you sit in front of a
computer more than uh
five hours a day 16 hours a day
wow um that what happens is that
it really kind of the computers and
everything kind of will stress your body
too especially if you have the computer
right next to your body i would try to
get as far away as possible
and even when you go to sleep at night
make sure there's no electrical stuff
right by your head
you got cell phones you know all that
stuff i i'm very
sensitive to um energies and i can pick
up like
i don't like talking in that cell phone
somehow it just like feels like there's
a microwave in my brain
so i'm like okay i gotta go you know
just that's why everyone's like what's
your cell phone number
i never pick it up because i don't like
that cell phone
so the adrenal when the adrenal gets
stressed
you can't tolerate stress and you start
increasing hormones that are going to
cause belly fat all right so this is an
adrenal body type shape right here
the weight is right there now why is it
in the belly
primarily because your body's in
survival and as a stress mechanism
you're going to hold it around the most
important organs which happen to be in
your midsection
your body's trying to survive it's
trying to help you it's protecting you
against starvation
that low calorie diet that you're going
to go on yeah so it's like going to put
it right here
how many sit ups will it take to flatten
that belly
it's not going to happen why because
it's coming from a hormone
your problem is not your weight it's
your hormones
you have to reduce that cortisol the
things that people do
to lose weight end up destroying their
metabolism and their hormones we don't
want to jack that
up anymore so people take stimulants
you're already stimulated you don't want
to jack it up more
so it goes there now over time instead
of burning the belly fat off as energy
it's going to burn off your leg muscles
before it even touches that fat
in other words your body is going to use
up your proteins and your your thighs
so guess what that's connected to your
knees that's why you have a lot of knee
problems with
with adrenal and you have a lot of
collagen because all the glue that holds
the body together falls apart so you
have
loose skin it's called pendulous abdomen
it kind of sags right here
and when you get it from a seated
position you're kind of like
getting up climbing is a problem your
legs are heavier
don't worry it gets worse so after these
legs become dissolved
then your adrenals will go after another
muscle called the glutamus
maximus what muscle is that you're
behind
so so what happens is not only do we get
us
thinner legs and bigger trunk but we get
no butt
so you got no butt no legs all belly
you've seen people like that right so
you have something to look forward to
i'm just gonna
i'm telling you you gotta you have to um
you gotta start now
just preventing okay um i've had
relatives
that before menopause oh my goodness
waste like this after
like that so yeah
so adrenal glands will cause all sorts
of problems with stress responses
and it affects their ability to
sleep normally when you go to sleep at
night you're supposed to go through
four waves of sleep
from a light sleep here to a deep sleep
here
now down here
in the lower parts this is called the
delta
wave sleep right here that's where you
burn
98 of all your fat not during
the day all the fat burning occurs
right there if you're not sleeping
you're not going to burn fat but in your
mind you're thinking you're wasting your
time i should be walking while i'm
sleeping
just to burn off those calories so let's
talk about calories for a second
yes exercise does burn calories
that's true but not necessarily fat
calories
let's take a look at something when a
normal person exercises
they actually stress their body out okay
sounds pretty interesting but what all
the benefit
from that exercise occurs in the
recovery 14 hours
just 24 hours later when you're in the
deep
sleep if you're sleeping if you let
yourself recover
you ever hear that workout called the
p90x or the insanity workout
i normally see people like 45 they start
doing that
you ever see the videos they have like
18 year olds
if you have low recovery like low
endurance low fitness
and you do that something that hot
you're going to hurt yourself you're
going to pull a hamstring
i see it all the time my son i took him
to wrestling practice
and he's like 16 17.
i was wrestling in college we go there
and all the fathers are
around the mat they're standing around
the perimeter with their shoes off with
their socks on
waiting to jump in there because they're
in their mind they're still 18.
one guy breaks the rib this guy you know
he runs out of almost like had a heart
attack
it was hilarious so mentally
you might still be 18 physically you may
not be
quite that level so it really all the
benefit occurs in the recovery after the
workout
so when you exercise you stress your
body and then you're supposed to recover
and that's when you burn the fat not
during the workout
if you don't believe me go work out
three hours and
weigh yourself before and after you'll
burn 900 calories
but no actual weight loss
okay so it's all right here if
you can recover adrenal cases
don't recover that well so they don't
adapt
so the exercise only as good as if you
can
change or adapt to it so that's really
what we're dealing with is how do you
get your body to change
from the things you're doing it how many
found when you're 18 you can pretty much
eat anything you want
and really you can just get away with it
right how many find you can't quite get
away with it now
what is the difference the difference is
your metabolism the rate
your metabolism okay that's really
what's broken
you really have to exercise based on
your ability to recover
from it it's better off for adrenals if
you go walking on a flat surface
than to get on that treadmill to burn
off the calories so the thing that
people do
cut calories starvation exhaustive
exercise is the exact thing that's
keeping that weight there and they're
frustrated because
they've been taught that oh everyone
knows
that you just have to exercise in diet
oh really
well those people are saying that i've
never probably worked with
one person i bet i've been there in the
field of weight loss for 25 years i
worked on 35 000 different people
i believe a patient because i observe
them
they're eating good and it's still not
working they're doing the treadmill it's
still not working so it really has to do
with
the internal so we want to adjust the
workout
to your ability to adapt that's why you
have to
you can't put everyone in the same
program everyone needs their their own
program
so with adrenaline they can't get to
sleep because they're so wound up and
they can't relax
because they're thinking so much or they
get up in the middle of the night like
two and just like they're more awake at
two than they are
during the day in fact right after lunch
or three o'clock they're just ready to
go to sleep so
either they can't get to sleep you can't
stay sleep or the bladder
which actually is controlled by the
adrenal has to
eliminate you know so they're getting up
urinating several times a night that's
adrenal
the best sleep for the adrenal is a half
hour before the alarm clock goes off
right there
right when you finally get to sleep
that's when you got to get out
can anyone relate to that yeah don't
worry it gets worse
um so we got the adrenal will affect the
sleep
create an inability to see change from a
workout
and it also will affect
your cognitive it affects a lot of other
things as well
it affects blood pressure yeah
that's one of the symptoms from the
adrenal is high blood pressure
especially of the top number the
systolic before the diastolic so always
look at the top number if the
top number is high we know it's adrenal
so because your body's
you lost that recovery mechanism to kind
of keep the pressure down
so you have blood pressure we have blood
sugar
yes diabetes is a symptom of adrenal
because they control the sugars
blood cholesterol is adrenal
yeah cholesterol is needed to make
adrenal hormones during stress the more
stress you go through
the more cholesterol you need to be able
to build those hormones
and then you have all allergies are
adrenal
including the sinus low vitamin d levels
are are adrenal you you know your doctor
saying go take vitamin d you're
deficient
but they're not asking why okay
arthritis all the itis in fact anything
connected with inflammation
is adrenal poor handwriting
and that's me um i could write the first
part of the
the word but the last just kind of gets
all lost
so what this means blood pressure blood
sugar blood cholesterol allergies
vitamin d
inflammation and cognitive
issues insomnia other than that you're
perfectly healthy
now here is the problem
what happens is that the medical system
treats treats these they don't
ask why there's no evaluation
what they'll do is take that symptom
okay
these are symptoms this is what symptom
is and then they make it the problem
okay they confuse the symptom with the
problem
it's like one of those obvious things
i'm like is it just me why is anyone
asking this question
because if you ask your doctor what
caused this what they'll do is convert
it to a very scientific complex name
okay you have lumbalgia what does that
mean
low back pain oh okay you have
fibromyalgia
what does that mean you got you're
hurting all over your body
uh you have plantar fasciitis what does
that mean you got pain in the foot
you have dystatokinesis sounds pretty
scientific that means you can't do this
with your body you can't rotate it back
and forth
you have spondylothesis what does that
mean you have a you have a broken back
there's all these labels post traumatic
stress syndrome you means you you've got
some stress in your past
they have one now called non-compliance
to treatment disorder
i'm serious i'm not kidding
non-compliance to treatment disorder
if you don't do what the doctor says
i told my son that and he said oh homie
don't play that i'm like
i said i said what does homie don't play
that mean he said
that means um i'm not going to do what
you say
i'm like oh okay then you're going to
get a diagnosis from the doctor
because he's going to go you have
non-compliance treatment disorder
well maybe you didn't want the surgery
maybe you want a second opinion and
they'll put this label
they have a manic depressive what does
that mean it means that you're happy and
sad
what's wrong with being happy you know
you have a clinical depression
it could mean that you're not sleeping
people that don't sleep get depressed
so it's just amazing and then it's
treated
with a poison i'm sorry a medication
my whole thought is that what's really
missing in healthcare
is the health part it's kind of like
that
i mean i don't know sometimes i'm like
did i just think of that is that
original idea or does everyone know that
i mean it's bizarre there's no health
and health care it's all disease care
there are underlying principles to all
subjects in life that are very high
principles that everything kind of must
revolve around
okay my whole principle in weight loss
is getting healthy lose weight
not losing weight to get healthy you
have to focus on your health
now that's pretty powerful because if
you don't know that you're very
susceptible to the next
unhealthy diet that comes along or a
little gimmick that
might not be healthy but if you look at
it from the viewpoint of
okay is that healthy yes okay that might
work
let's just take the word food
how many of you eat food okay yeah
how many of you never looked up the
definition of the word food before
okay i'm going to tell you what it is is
that which is eating sustained life
provide energy and promote the growth
and repair of tissue
it comes from the latin word which means
nourishment
nutrients so food is nutrients that's
why we
supposed to eat it we're not supposed to
eat food for necessarily anything other
than health and nutrients
but so when you go into the grocery
store you can ask now
what am i in the mood for no no don't
ask that because you're going to get a
brownie
but if you say what can get me more
nutrition what's
what can i eat that has more nutrition
that's very powerful because then you
get to stay out of trouble
i guarantee all the junk foods don't
have a lot of nutrition they don't other
than synthetic vitamins
in politics you have underlying
principles that you use
like the i guess the principle in
politics or the underlying
senior principle would be something like
don't spend more than you have
right in the budget would that be kind
of a smart thing get out of trouble
so i guess we have to worry about that
one just being sarcastic
um and then you have um what about in um
in the area of health in general you
have to
or health care you have to create your
health
can you imagine if we just put
one percent of the of the money we put
in sick care or health care into just
prevention or
creating health it's over it's over i
mean
prevention the problem is the doctors
will say okay let's check in six months
okay and you keep coming back let's
check you let's check you
sorry to tell this you have cancer get
your stuff together
and it's we're going to do chemo what
was to be done to prevent it what was
done to create the health
there's nothing what are they going to
do an aspirin a day
i had to get life insurance okay at
least i'm still trying to figure out why
my wife wanted to get life insurance
so i go to the doctor my cholesterol is
uh
180 it's pretty good doctor says well
it's normal but we're going to prevent
we're going to we're going to practice
some preventative medication
like what what do you talk about
ceremony because i know what we're just
doing on everyone right now
i'm like no thank you no it's because no
no i have a free sample
lipitor i'm like no that is side effects
because oh no that's you can't believe
the articles you can't believe
i'm like you're gonna kick back
so the point is that there's a lot of
corruption in the area of
pharmaceuticals and drugs you already
know that
but the point is that you have to start
creating your health
because the doctors just don't know how
i train doctors i train over 2 400
doctors
they're not taught how to get someone
healthy other than the food pyramid
drink more water eat more fiber you know
it's just like it's not significant
so you really have to learn how to
create health yourself
and start building your health because
no one else is going to do it for you
cancer takes 20 years to grow in your
body
i mean all of you probably have some
cancer cells in your body it's what
you're doing in your environment that's
countering that right now to protect you
you
literally you have to create your health
every day
so i look at people a little differently
like what i'll do when i'm listening to
people
i'll just dissect them in half and i'll
go okay what are the things they're
doing to create their health
and what are the things they're doing to
counter create their health because
doing nothing is counter-creating right
so and it's amazing it makes it so
simple
i'm like wow like wow look at this
like you don't have you don't realize
that
many people don't realize that the
cravings
are a very simple nutrient deficiency
potassium
when you have low potassium you will
crave
sugar guaranteed when you get your daily
amount of potassium you will not crave
sugar it's that simple
how many have craved sugar okay if i
tell you what to do
would you would you do it to get rid of
cravings within 24 hours or actually 48
hours
okay so do this thing right here normal
amount of potassium we need is 4 700
milligrams a day
now what food are is high in potassium
bananas right
that's 400 okay how many bananas would
it take
12 12 bananas right
so you're not going to do 12 bananas
okay
so the amount of potassium you need is
so high
you don't even realize it there's a lot
of potassium so what you can do
is you can have all the leafy greens you
would need seven cups
to seven cups it's not hard couple
salads a day
and you will fulfill your daily amount
requirement for potassium
you won't you will not have cravings
it's wonderful to help protect against
diabetes
this right here because when you have
that potassium it helps stabilize your
blood sugars
but how many of you really don't consume
seven cups of salad a day
hardly anyone does how the heck are you
ever going to get your potassium
so um this is the problem is we don't
really know what foods have the right
nutrients
and and the soils are so depleted if you
would if you wanted to get
your basic nutrients of trace minerals
okay those are little minerals that you
need in small amounts
in your food right now with the soils
the way they are
you would have to consume 27
000 calories of food
yeah so that's going to be pretty hard
isn't it that's a lot of food eating
every day
so you're going to have to subs or
enhance your diet with something
just make sure it's the right nutrients
plant-based you have to concentrate
but yeah that's this is the problem is
that people don't know how to create
health
and so it's kind of crazy
so so we have the adrenal we have uh
with the problem with the adrenal is you
get fluid retention because all the
electrolytes are controlled
the sodium potassium is controlled by
the adrenal in other words when you have
adrenal problems you lose potassium
your salts and electro all these things
that keep the fluid
moving are gone so the fluid is going to
pull in your ankles
when you press your ankle and leaves a
little dent that's fluid retention
you shouldn't have that okay go ahead
and press your ankle and see if you have
any
indentations there
can you call 9-1-1 so fluid
in the ankles is purely an electrolyte
problem because the adrenal it's
backing up fluid so we have that we're
going to have salt cravings for adrenal
too
salt cravings that's adrenal salt is the
is the mineral that recharges the
battery that's why you need a little
chip at night when you go home
i mean just to recharge your battery
because you're drained
most of you are like a car in the
freeway the battery is dead and you're
putting gas in the car
why doesn't this thing start now you're
pushing the car it's getting kind of
heavy
so electrolytes fluid now how much water
should you drink
eight classes right who told you that
they told you someday
i'm going to find out who they is
because
that is a myth i was taught that you
drink
i still can't find the uh where do you
find this information
only drink when you're thirsty here's
what i found the more water you drink
the more dehydrated you become
why because it flushes out the
electrolytes that are supposed to hold
the water
there there's a condition right now that
i think it's called um hyponutremia
which is actually too much water which
is flushing electrolytes and you can die
die by drinking too much water so
drink when you're thirsty i have a
machine i measure fluid in
a person's body normally people that
drink the most water the most dehydrated
don't worry it gets worse so
they is everywhere it's nowhere it's
like i don't know who they is
so you have fluids we have calcium
calcium is controlled by the adrenal
not just bone loss not just muscle
cramps
but you need calcium to have to wind
down at night
without good adrenals your calcium will
deposit
not in the bone but on the bone as
arthritis bursitis tendinitis
tartar in your teeth cataracts kidney
stones
gallstones bursitis all the itis and
twitching in the left eyelid right here
yeah that's calcium so again what do
people take
calcium carbonate limestone it's in the
one a days
any time you get a vitamin that's
prescribed prescription
at a pharmacy oh my goodness that's like
how low can you go it's just
way off the deep end it's just going to
be rocks
you need plant-based minerals this is
how it works
the plant is supposed to break down the
minerals like rocks in the earth
and absorb them into the plant and make
them easy to digest
the plant-based minerals are 10
000 times smaller than rocks and
metallic minerals that you get like sea
salts
ten thousand times smaller so that would
be the equivalent to a
um a golf ball to the empire state
building
so you absorb these plant-based minerals
so
much better you ever find that when you
eat food you don't feel satisfied like
it just doesn't quite
even water just doesn't satisfy you
because the nutrients aren't there why
do you think you keep craving
so it's just it's a deficiency so we
have
sinus problems oh that's another
diagnosis sleep apnea what does that
mean it means that your sinuses are
blocked
it's like very i mean it's just amazing
how it's gotten out of control
and so right now the answer to
healthcare is not spending more
money on it it's just to do more
prevention the whole philosophy is
broken
but there's no money in prevention it's
too cheap
i mean it's very cheap in fact i can
take
every one of your grocery bills and
probably find
a hundred dollars every two weeks of a
food that you could just switch over to
healthier food
and just and just take that and create
health it's not that hard it's just
choices what to eat
in the grocery store why do i know this
because i go in the grocery store and i
see what they have
it's so bad it's amazing like wow people
must be buying that
because it's there i mean trying to find
food in the grocery store it's not easy
it's like um so we have adrenal any
other question about the adrenal
body type it's kind of an interesting
type snoring because the sinuses
there's a nerve that goes in the back of
the sinuses that if
the adrenal gland shrinks it because the
cortisol and it actually makes us
thicker so you're like
you know snoring so we have
adrenal now um the other thing is that
of course my wife says that sometimes
i make that sound i'm like no i don't
she goes okay i'm gonna record you i'm
like okay you can prove it so
that's adrenal
now the next body type is the ov ovary
body type
this is it right here see this body type
look where they gain the weight lower
part in the hips
thighs that's estrogen dominance take a
while to guess why you don't see very
many men that look
like that they don't have ovaries very
good
so the ovary will out produce too much
estrogen the estrogen makes
fat around the superficial from here
down it will also make your arms get big
and the breasts get big i had one
patient she was so estrogen dominant she
became a size
h i didn't even know it goes that high
i thought d double triple d was the
highest
let's see a b c d e f g h
yeah that's estrogen dominance how do
you know if you're estrogen dominant
if you look like that and also you have
heavy periods
cramping pms all that guess what that's
going to do
it's going to make a fibroid i see so
many women with fibroids
it's estrogen dominance so what's the
solution
cut it out i mean they're not doing
anything there are foods that you can
eat right now that will balance estrogen
it's called the cruciferous vegetable
cruciferous vegetables are like kale
broccoli brussels sprouts cabbage
all the foods that no one eats those are
very estrogen
they clean up the estrogen they balance
it and the chemicals
thank goodness we have those foods in
our diet um
if we ever eat them but mainly people
cook the heck out of them don't they
yeah so
um estrogen dominant will cause anything
wrong with this cycle
heavy periods headaches that time of the
month uh cravings that time of the month
um pms how many of you know people that
are pms
okay i can see the husbands are not like
they're like
so you have all these different issues
that happen that time of the month if
it's cyclic
because the hormones go on waves just
like all these circadian waves
um fertility infertility because
estrogen you know what's really amazing
things
you have this estrogen dominant patient
and guess what they give them
birth control pills it's the exact
opposite thing
you're going to put it more in estrogen
dominance
what foods should they stay away from
soy
why because soy is very estrogenic
and the soy that's in america is not the
same that's another place it's not
fermented it's like
it's just soy powder it's soy protein
isolates what does that do
it's going to grow tumors in your liver
and your um in your um
where else in the ovaries in the uterus
it'll grow tumors it's very tumor
producing
yeah i see it all the time there were
even some men that came in they were
drinking so much soy milk they started
lactating that was enough for me to cut
it completely out of the diet
but there's estrogen is very very um
bad for the liver and um
it's every it's in almost a lot it's in
a lot of foods isn't it it's genetically
modified
it's almost 100 genetically modified in
the us and that means they alter the
structure so there's a lot of unknowns
right now there's no studies so um you
know it doesn't have to be on the label
too to be genetically modified
they could just stick it in there so you
have soy it's in also in a lot of
prepackaged foods a lot of diets
yeah isn't that interesting the stuff
that causes estrogen is in these eyes
why do they use it because it's so cheap
it's so cheap i made a kale shake
with um i was going to put some protein
and the guy that was helping me develop
the formula says oh you got to put some
soy and it's really cheap
i'm like i'm not going to put that in
there that's going to like kill people
so i put um spirulina
that's like a veg vegeta a vegetable um
a sea vegetable so it has some egg white
organic egg white and kale
but the point is that you don't want to
do a lot of estrogen
with that because then you want to make
sure if they're doing meats and dairy
they have organic hormone free
this body type craves
dairy they like ice cream cheese
yogurt it's wow they're trying to get
some hormones in there to try to balance
something because they're out of balance
it won't ever work though so they have a
lot of issues with that
and then when they get to be age 52
the ovaries stop working
okay but guess what you have a backup
organ here's the ovaries
the adrenals are little triangles on top
of the kidney
these start doing the work so now if the
adrenal glands are weak going in the
menopause
you're going to overload those things
and now this is going to do all the work
and so now you're going to have all
sorts of problems with
hot flash flashes night sweats
okay does anyone have a hot flash okay
so hot flashes are basically
a short circuit in the electrical system
of your body
that's just kind of like it's blowing
that heat right there someone's having a
hot flash right now
um so that would be hot flashes
so this body type ends up looking like
this body type after menopause so what
am i trying to tell you i'm trying to
give you a clue
that you better do something now before
it's too late
now some of you in your mind you're
thinking wow i'm a mixed body type
i'm everything right you always have a
primary
too much estrogen will block the thyroid
that's why when you get pregnant you
might end up with a thyroid problem
because the excess estrogen will block
this
and then create all sorts of problems
many many borderline thyroid cases need
to take thyroid medication when they're
pregnant because of the spike of
estrogen
so all these things work together
if the liver is bad which we're going to
get to
next your thyroid can't work the ear
thyroid needs
that liver to convert like 80 of all the
activation of that hormone curse with
your liver
so i had a lady she came in she did the
wrong
diet for her body type she did the high
protein diet
okay she was a liver type liver types
should not do high protein diets okay
what happened she lost weight but she
also lost all of her hair
well she had two gray hairs uh she had a
wig a very nice wig
um and she came in and she said doctor
gotta help me i'm like okay what's going
on
she goes look at i was like okay yes we
need to we need to work on that
so i said um what happened to you
she goes i just did this diet i lost all
my hair i said bingo
you mess with your liver and then the
block the thyroid
now here's the problem she was gonna she
was she was gonna get married okay
her husband future husband had no clue
she was completely
bald okay that's the situation wouldn't
you
it's like it's it's like the honeymoon
night um
honey now that we're married um surprise
and then he pulls off his toupee
i think there was like a movie where you
can pull off your arm and your leg
so i worked on her i do a technique
which which works on old stress it's an
acupressure not puncture and we worked
on her
and worked on the liver and she got her
hair back in three weeks tiny little
hair she came back she was real happy
got married never told them went great
yeah so these hormones have
dominating things dominating
power to do certain things
we when you actually age
when you go from 20s 30s 40s 50s okay
hormones change metabolism
slows down would you agree with that
you can't keep doing the same thing
with the calorie counting you have to
look at
the hormones in relationship to the
triggering of the fat burning hormones
i'm going to show you something before i
get to the next body type real fast
hormones there are three dominating
hormones that if present in small
amounts
will completely block and cancel all the
fat
burning hormones okay in other words
you have two things you have things that
you should avoid and you have things
that you should do
the things that you should avoid are
much much much much more important
than the things that you should do it's
the little stuff okay
so let's take this one the first one is
called insulin insulin is a hormone that
regulates sugar it decreases sugar it's
triggered by sugar so every time you eat
sugar
it spikes the insulin okay then you
become a diabetic and then sugar goes
high it doesn't go down so you have to
take
insulin in the presence of just a little
tiny bit of insulin
it can cancel out and completely destroy
all the good stuff that you did so let's
just make this real
let's take a cookie 80 calories
you can walk that off in about a mile
but the sugar in that one cookie
will will block that burning for 72
hours if you have a slow metabolism
like most people do a half a glass of
orange juice
a glass of wine unless dr oz told you to
do it
which i'm just being sarcastic because
i'm like wine is alcohol it's sugar it's
like
it's going to completely block you so we
got insulin right
it's the little stuff that's going to
really mess you up so we have to
we have to give you substitutes for the
thing you crave i already know
a habit is almost impossible to break so
we don't want to take all the pleasure
away from you in life
we want to tweak it so there's things
you can eat
brownies for example that have no sugar
no flour
and you can eat those you just have to
know how to make them when we have the
recipes we give you
and you can actually have it in the
refrigerator and go for that
every night or when you when you like
that
number two cortisol
too much cortisol that's the stress
you're not going to lose weight and that
how do you get rid of stress sleeping
walking i teach people to do an
acupressure technique which basically
pulls the stress out you do it before
bed and you just get into a good sleep
and it extracts the old stress so
cortisol will block
fat burning that's why you have like
when you have physical trauma and then
you have losses
loss of a loved one or a divorce
whatever that will hit the adrenal a
thousand times harder than a physical
trauma
that's why you have people that like
after like this major event they're just
like they never recover that's why you
get autoimmune diseases like
lupus and ms they all come after losses
okay so then we have the last hormone
that
makes you fat is called estrogen
remember all those hidden sources of
estrogen it's in the hormones
in europe people are thinner than
americans
in america we got girls going through
the menstrual cycle a lot earlier
larger breasts kids are fatter
you might say it's a lot of different
things but i think the hormones are
really messing us up
if you now you guys realize that turkeys
are fed hormones
that's why they're bigger they're huge
right they can grow them fast
if you consume the turkey that's been
injected with a hormone
is it possible that some of that residue
can get in your body
if it makes a turkey a butterball turkey
is it possible to make a butterball out
of you butterball turkey
welcome to america you're in the wrong
country at the wrong time
so some of these poor countries they're
really rich in nutrients
but they come here and they just get
that i see it all the time they moved to
america i'm like you're doing fine so
you moved here
welcome to virginia so we have to eat
and understand how to fortify our
hormones okay
that's really important so last body
type is called the liver body type
the liver is located right here the size
of a football
it's three and a half pounds put your
hand on your liver
it's on the right side the military
right over here
okay good your liver
is kind of an extra organ you don't
really need it i'm just being sarcastic
the liver if if it becomes dysfunctional
you're going to start getting more of a
protruded
pot belly okay you ever see the guy in
the beach with a speedo
sorry to give that image but that's kind
of like a basketball belly
it's hard it's higher if you take your
hand on one side and tap it it'll create
a little ripple
why because most of it's fluid
it's called ascites it's a fluid it
means fluid it's leak the liver is
leaking fluid into that sac right there
so how many sit-ups won't work sit-ups
won't work
their legs are skinny it's just right
there
it's not just beer it's actually fluid
coming from destruction of the liver
the two foods that destroy the liver are
heavy
cooked proteins animal proteins
heavy cooked texas style steaks this
thick big ones every night before you go
to bed
deep fried food deep fried catfish will
do it too
just all that fat and meat will just
destroy the liver so the worse the liver
the more you can't tolerate the heavy
proteins the older you get
the less you can tolerate red meat so
what happens is that you want to adjust
the
food based on your weakness but the good
thing about the liver
it's the only organ that can completely
regenerate a hundred percent
but the bad news is it takes three years
of eating a certain way
okay the liver is the hub of so many
things
the liver will cause a liver problem
will cause pain on the right side right
shoulder why is it on the right shoulder
the liver is on the right it's going to
be swell up it's going to go right here
if you have a liver problem don't sleep
on your left side because it's too heavy
it's going to compress the heart
you're going to feel uncomfortable
you'll sleep on the right side
the liver will create little red spots
on your skin
little red dot skin psoriasis
eczema little liver spots itchy skin
hot feet white tongue that's a yeast
chronic halitosis that's bad breath
sometimes they usually talk to you very
close in front of your face
they don't know that they have bad
breath it's like
really um they have a lot of digestive
bloating
okay now the liver
makes bile now there's a confusion about
bile some people think it's bowel
no no that's bowel bile b-i-l-e
bile helps it's like the detergent that
breaks down the grease
it helps you digest the fats and it
helps you absorb
the fat vitamins that cyber vitamins
vitamin a
if you're deficient about mna you're
going to have a hard time seeing at
night
you're going to have sinus problems
you're going to have dry skin
you're going to have a little uh yellow
thing in your inside of your eye right
here a little
tag there there's a lot of issues with
vitamin a vitamin d you're gonna have
problems with calcium
you're gonna have problems with seasonal
depression vitamin e you're gonna have
problems with libido vitamin um let's
see a
e d and k you're gonna have bruising
so you have a lot of other issues just
for me doing a bio how do you know if
you don't have bile you're gonna
bloat when you eat you're gonna get
bloating
burping belching headache on the right
side
98 percent of headaches and migraines
are coming from
that right there try and experiment
next time you get a headache press right
here
on your gallbladder just press right
there and just hold that for two minutes
your headache will go right away the
problem is not in your head
it's in your down here because when you
step on a dog's tail he barks through
his mouth right
okay i'm just checking so we get
bloating burping belching many people
don't have the bile
and they're bloat when they like at
night they feel like they're pregnant
yet during the day they have flat
stomach
is that real to anyone okay so
the liver they they crave deep fried
catfish they like deep-fried anything
because they're not absorbing it
so you're gonna want the stuff that you
can't absorb the other symptom is that
when you eat you're gonna need a little
sweet after you eat
you need that little sweet because
you're not digesting fats to satisfy
your blood sugars
okay you're going to be grouchy in the
morning because you have a low blood
sugar in the morning
how many work with people that are
grouchy in the morning okay
so what you do on monday when you go
back to work just go up to
uh go up to the guy hey john listen
you know i've been holding a grudge on
you because you've been very kind of
grouchy
but now i know it's just your liver i
forgive you
or the next time you go the all you eat
buffet
just go online excuse me sir
have you ever had your liver checked do
you have any right shoulder pain
do you ever itch in the bottom of your
feet let me see your tongue for a second
here's dr berg's card you might want to
give him a call do you get bloating by
the way
actually don't mention my name if you
say that um
they might get offended see the problem
with teaching you this seminar is you're
going to want to evaluate everyone you
know everywhere you go you're going to
spot oh
liver third two two two sorry
so that is liver um
liver is uh they do very well on
cruciferous vegetables okay
any other questions about the body types
yes
i notice you have the man the male there
with the
liver and i know a male cannot have a
very ovary
what about the other what would it look
like to see a male
um it's very rare so she asked question
why
what would it look like if there's a
male with these other ones it's did
it's very rare to have a primary thyroid
body type it's usually secondary to
having the thyroid removed because of
estrogen dominance
too much estrogen is underneath most of
the thyroids i mean it's just it's
almost not
existent this is very common this this
adrenal right here just because of
stress that's probably the number one
thing
you see this because of just bad eating
from years
but the ovary is very common too so this
one here these three are very common
so if if that guy was
a thyroid they would just be big all
over
if that guy was adrenal he would have
more of a sagging belly it wouldn't be
so high in the top
okay and of course he wouldn't have that
typically
let's see he had a lot of soy milk
now this next thing i'm going to tell
you is so important
it's the most important thing that i
have to talk about so if anyone's
checked out
check back in right now do you hear
you've heard that obesity is a health
risk right it causes
diabetes heart attack stroke
cancer bad luck right everything right
that's what i was taught too but i found
that's absolutely
not true it's a myth let me explain
i had a patient come in 29 years old
weighed 325 pounds
did my program this is a long time ago
take a while guess how much weight she
lost in the first month
nope nope nope
nope no exactly it's
zero pounds she lost zero pounds okay
now who would be depressed if you lost
zero weight yeah
but she was actually okay with it
because she felt better okay
the second month she lost 21 pounds
the third month she lost 63 pounds
it was at that point when i had a light
bulb go off
i'm like wow you don't you don't lose
weight and get healthy
you get healthy to lose weight see i've
been doing it the other way around
that changed my whole practice because
now everything that i aligned
was going to get them healthy and i
started to see results on people that
wouldn't normally ever get results
it's the health you cannot be fat and
healthy at the same time
being healthy the weight comes off as a
natural side effect
obesity is a symptom of an unhealthy
body not the cause of it
why are they doing that why are they
pushing it so they can come up with the
drugs to treat it again it's a symptom
does this make sense so
here's what i want you to do i want you
to change
your viewpoint goal from
losing weight to creating more health go
ahead and do it right now
go ahead and just shift make the shift
come on
in the back there shift it okay good so
have you decided that you'll create more
health
because that's how you do it forget
about the diets
we have to get your lifestyle corrected
forget about vitamins unless you can get
your eating corrected
because understanding that is a superior
principle
that will take you not just to lose
weight but to get younger as you get
older
i'm 65 no i'm just kidding
no i'm 47 but i feel like i'm
25 i mean i wrestle
my kids and i um and i'm like i'm
working out
i'm actually trying to reverse the aging
process and so
that's what i want you guys to do every
year you get older you're getting
younger
but all it takes is a shift of viewpoint
rather than oh here's the diet you have
to understand what to do
so there's three things i want you to do
number one find out your body type
number two get in a plan that's specific
for your body type
and number three to it through creating
healthy habits that you can do long term
so it's all about create your health
every day it has to be built
just like everything else in life
i want to thank you guys for coming i
hope you learned something i appreciate
your attention this long
have a great afternoon